From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mekaella Vailu'u: Hello everyone.
I want to thank you for coming.
My name is Mekaella
Vailu'u and I am here
from Eastern Kentucky University.
I'm currently an intern in
interpreting services program
which is housed in the EE ODP.
During my tenure here, I'll be
planning three different events.
The first one is commencing today
and then the other two
are up here on the board.
Each event is planned all at the
same time just for continuity
so that everybody can come
and you'll remember this
time, so you can come now.
While I'm here I wanted
to look around the Library
to see the different ways
that language was used,
within each division there
is unique language and I want
to introduce Alex Richey to you.
He'll be facilitating this
panel discussion today.
So again thank you for coming and
hope you enjoy the presentation.
>> Alex Richey: Hello everyone.
My names Alex Richey, I'm
a retiree with the Library.
I had almost forty three years
of service here at the Library
and I'm coming back as a
volunteer with my old job.
So I'd like the other panelists
to introduce themselves.
Also, where I'm working
is geography and map,
I'm still volunteering there.
>> Gerald Voltman: My
name is Gerald Voltman.
I'm currently in the CALM division
and I have been here for six years.
>> Fred Pickering:
Hello, I'm Fred Pickering.
I've worked [inaudible] OIT OCIO.
I've been here for more than forty
years and I work with the people
with disabilities with
their [inaudible].
>> Alex Richey: The first picture on
the left is the original telephone
that was invented in 1875
by Alexander Graham Bell,
here pictured in the middle
with his wife and his mother.
They were all deaf, I'm sorry,
the wife and the mother were deaf
and he was working on
inventing hearing aid
and by accident he
invented the telephone.
And it was something that for many,
many years almost a 100 years was
of no benefit to the deaf world
until about the 1970s there
was a man, well, here we go,
1875 nearly a hundred
years until the invention
of the modem and teletype in 1964.
The teletypewriter is where
the term TTY comes from and man
who invented was Robert Weitbrecht
and this book was written
by Harry Lang, a historian,
that chronicled that time.
And Robert Weitbreht was the
adventure of the modem and the TTY.
Does anyone here remember
the sign for this telephone?
Yes, that's the one.
Yes, that's the sign we
used to use that telephone
and this telephone, right?
Telephone or you actually show it
lifting it up and you will dial;
it was a dial, rotary
dial phone at that time.
So who here had either one of those?
Anyone have the older version?
>> No, no.
>> Alex Richey: No, the other
one, you had the rotary dial,
you had the rotary dial phone, okay.
Now, I've seen the
handheld ones in museums
but didn't see one in real life.
Now, this is the model twenty
eight teletypewriter, it's a TTY.
And it was actually a teletypewriter
machine that had to be connected
with this modem and that was the
invention that turned it into a TTY
that we could use the
phone to communicate
from one person to another.
And who's this?
Oh yeah, that's a deaf man, yes.
Someone from the audience asked
me if this person was deaf?
That's Robert.
>> Gerald Voltman: Fred is asking,
where was that machine from?
Where was that made?
>> Alex Richey: Correct, it was from
the Western Union telegraph company
and so many deaf people way
back then had those phones.
They had to be refurbished when
they came from Western Union
and then deaf people
would sell them.
Myself, I had one of this.
How many here had one of this?
>> Fred Pickering: Yeah,
they were extremely noisy
and a lot a vibration from them.
>> Alex Richey: And the question
from the audience was right.
Some people have seen them
but they never use them yet.
It depends on what
generation you are from.
I remember in my high school,
it was a mainstream
school, they still had one.
We really got tired of those
large, noisy, loud machines
and we finally came up
with a portable TTY.
You didn't have to have that big
lugging equipment in your house.
Now, the first teletypewriter
that came out came
out without paper,
we'll talk about that.
And the second ones came
out with paper and a lot
of deaf people really preferred
the ones with the paper printout
because you could refresh your
memory about what was being said.
The other ones if the message
scrolled by on the LED screen,
it was really hard to remember
what was said, especially,
if English was your second language,
it was harder to keep up with that
and I guess I'll pass it off
to the panel for comment.
>> Gerald Voltman: Yes that's right,
my TTY had an answering
machine ready inside of it
and so it would go ahead
and leave the message for me
so if I wasn't home I could see
what was being said while I was out.
>> Fred Pickering: I used those,
I think a mini com, I believe.
When I would call into
the relay service
and I'd see its rolling
cross, I would call relay
and the person will answer the
phone near and would ask me,
what did you say, can
you repeat that?
And I could remember exactly
what I had said before
or what had been said so we typed
something, it was there, it was gone
and so you didn't have a
record of what you were saying
or what had been said previously.
So it could be a problem
sometimes once you have the paper
if someone asked me
to repeat something
or whatever I could go back in
and get verbatim what I had said.
>> Alex Richey: Sometimes when
I was typing I had to wait
for the relay operator to
speak my message in English,
to listen to the other person
and then type it back to me.
It really was very time-consuming.
>> Fred Pickering: I talked
with deaf people who've
used the TTY before
and they didn't like the waiting.
Because you would, the hearing
people also found it very
frustrating because it was much
slower communication having to wait
for someone to type
what they were saying
to hear a response
back, it took forever.
>> Alex Richey: So technology came
out with new and better things.
Pagers, I think Gerald, you
actually have one, right?
There's still 4 deaf people at the
Library of Congress who use pagers,
it's for emergency notification
because they work in the stacks
and that's the only reason
that they're still using
that older technology.
How many even remember those?
Now, Instant Messenger
AOL, I didn't use it much
but how many of you used it.
>> Gerald Voltman: Yeah, I
used to use that before text
but then once I have text
message I get rid of AIM.
>> Alex Richey: Right,
everyone always keeps moving
to new and better technology.
Now, the last one over here was
something specifically for the deaf,
it was called the sidekick.
How many of you had a sidekick?
Yeah, a lot of folks had
the sidekick at that time.
So let's talk about.
So let's talk about
the signs for these.
So some people would
sign pager like this.
Gerald saying I would sign it here,
right, Alex is showing the sign.
Instant Messenger, we always say AIM
and then sidekick, that's the sign
for the sidekick if I may.
>> Fred Pickering: As far as AIM
and AOL AIM, it was very popular
for a lot of deaf people; it
was very easy communication.
The person had it, they had
Internet access at home or whatever,
you could just jet back-and-forth,
it was very popular, extremely.
So AIM outside the outside world,
here's the Library for example,
they didn't permit it
for security reasons.
So we couldn't use AIM here
internally, just email.
And [inaudible] text on a pagers or
things like that but AIM got removed
and because hackers could
sometimes use those to sort
of get back into the system.
Now we have, the group was there's
a messenger replacement so a lot
of people really do miss AIM.
>> Alex Richey: Alright, so
let's talk about other technology
that improved over the years.
Let's talk about the signs
first, this is a cell phone,
cell phone will, yeah, but it was
for hearing people not
for deaf people, right?
Okay, so that's the sign
cell phone and then.
Okay. So there's another
sign, but I'm going to use
that a little bit later in the
presentation and then this,
these smart phones were
much more easy to use.
Now, this is what we would
classify as a cell phone
and that was the sign and then
this is the sign for iPhone.
There's the letter I in the
same place is a telephone
or a mobile phone, well,
mobile that you carry with you.
>> Gerald Voltman: There's another
sign for like the iPhone or an iPad
but just the swiping
and scrolling motion.
>> Fred Pickering: And
everyone I'm sure will.
Most deaf people use
some sort of iPhone
or Samsung, some kind of smartphone.
Because you can text back and
forth with that very easily,
email and now with some of the video
relay they have apps on the phones.
You can contact the video relay
service through your cell phone
as well through your smartphone.
You can call to ask for directions
somewhere if you're stuck
at some place, it's very
nice to be able to get
that access, use it for that.
>> Alex Richey: So one
thing I wanted to add,
I'm going to step back in
time here a little bit.
At first all of this technology
was set out to hearing people
and the telephone companies
created that,
but you had to ask your neighbors
to make telephone calls for you
and so that was a problem.
Anyone else wants to say
something about that about using.
>> Sure, I know in the past
if I was making calls, first,
I would, I saw it at Gallaudet.
I saw it back in 1967, 68 something
like that, I saw how supervisor,
then supervisor there had a device,
they were writing something on it.
>> Alex Richey: On the screen?
>> Hand write something and it
would go down into this machine.
They were using something to
scroll round on it and send it
to another office and they
had a similar machine there
that was then sort of had a pin
following what they were doing.
So you'll be writing out
messages at the same time,
it was all in handwriting
and they go back
and forth that way communicating.
TTY is a very different machine,
obviously, typing back and forth
but I do remember seeing that at
Gallaudet, it was very interesting
to see, I hadn't thought
about for years
because the technology
changed so much.
>> Alex Richey: I think
that's about writing,
noting, giving them to someone.
>> Sure, I write notes and give
them back and forth to people
but often I want the person to come
up to me and as me directions here
or there, things like that,
in case that [inaudible] deaf,
and they start to walk away.
I am so willing to help
and I'm able to help,
I can grab paper whatever
write back and forth,
I can I know where I'm going,
I can give you directions.
So I'm very willing to help.
Today we have so much new
technology with the pagers
and texting and all of that.
You'll be able to type the speech
technology like I can type a message
and they can speak them to you.
Alex Voltman: Alex is saying,
my team leader uses Siri
on the iPhone a lot.
We will speak to it and
it types for the person
and then I read the
message so that works
out pretty well and
I type back to them.
And that's all part of
smartphone, iPhone technology.
Anything else you want
to add about these?
Toby do you have any
thing you want to add?
>> Do you want to mention
about them about the C phone?
I haven't heard about that.
>> Toby French: Hello everybody.
I'm Toby French and I have
worked with the library
for thirty four years but as
of March 15th I will be celebrating
my 51st year in federal service.
So I didn't realize,
thank God I'm alive
and I would say I have
really enjoyed my time here
but before the time when we had
a mini com, and it was C phone,
it was a little TV screen and you
would put a phone up against it.
And I remember one day,
one evening rather,
lightning had struck the C phone
and it didn't work anymore,
but at that time there was a
newer model and so we were able
to update to that version.
The C phone was about
two or three years old
when I was able to use that.
>> Alex Richey: So there's another
question from the audience here.
We're trying to remember
all of our stories.
This is Toby speaking and
saying I remember the C phone,
it wasn't like a telephone with
screen but it didn't really last,
it wasn't the best technology.
So you're saying that the
screen was really small.
>> Toby French: Yeah, it was
like you would put the
phone vertical almost
up against the screen, it's
not this big foot by foot.
>> Alex Richey: Yeah, I
think I seen phones like that
but the screens were like four
by four inches something
smaller like that.
>> Everything, I've seen
something on a website about one
of the little phones like that.
>> Alex Richey: And Eric
thank you for prompting me.
We were talking about the
stories that we'd remembered here.
Here at the library, when I came
into the library there were
no telephones they were used
by deaf people.
So we wrote back and
forth and used telephones
with our hearing colleagues and
then I think it was about nineteen.
>> Eighty?
>> Alex Richey: Yes,
somewhere around 1980.
Here's the Library of Congress,
the Library of Congress bought one,
one TTY for all of us and
the impact was amazing.
We have three different buildings
and we would all have to trek
to the one building
where the one TTY was
and sometimes there would be a line,
they were like get off the phone
so I can make my call and
waiting queue for that.
Then later on we got one in
each building, and then later
on every deaf employee got
their own TTY at their desk.
So at least there was one TTY for
everyone but I think I've got caught
up on other stories, is that right?
>> I know, when I originally
got hired and the first day
that I got here they
had one ready for me
because you're a newer
employee, that's why.
>> Alex Richey: I'm an old timer
and I can remember the days
when we saw all of this progress
incrementally over time, alright.
Okay so here we are.
We're going to talk
about these devices.
We call them now VPs,
videophones, there was a sign
that we started off using was
like two cameras, two cameras
and that were used simultaneously.
We got tired of doing that
so we decided to sign it
with just two letters VP.
>> When I was a student's
at NTID there were a lot
of different offices that
would have all around campus
that would have different videophone
stationed that if we needed to use.
And they had phones that we could
just sit there and sign into
and we could communicate
that way using a video phone.
But now that was probably in
like 1994 and that was in NTID.
So now, we have videophones
everywhere.
>> Alex Richey: Well, who wants
to speak about these next, Fred.
>> Fred Pickering: I
don't see the difference
in the TTY and the videophone.
I can speak to that a bit.
The TTY deaf persons talking about,
you're typing back and forth,
it's a second language
for a lot of deaf people,
it's very confusing sometimes
having to go back and try
and reread what they said
in English and English
and ASL are different languages.
So it really did extend the time
that it took to have a conversation,
they dragged everything out.
The hearing person was having to
wait for often the deaf person
to get the message typed them
and interpreted themselves
and the operators on the videophone;
it's a very different feel.
These are just one of my
friends that I'm talking with,
here in the picture we're
having a direct communication
but I also use this
within interpreter the exact same
way you see in the other picture.
I'll be, the hearing person will be
speaking same time and I'm signing
and then interprets managing it
all like the interpreters do.
Normally people can call
me, I can call them.
I can call directly
to deaf people as well
with the video relay service.
It's all coordinated very simply
and easily through an interpreter
through ASL so there's far
fewer misunderstandings.
The interpreters understand what the
deaf person is saying more clearly
that they are able to
interpret them more clearly.
The video relay service
is a much better option
and it makes us better
communicators and train them to set
up doctors appointments,
to set up whatever.
For the TTY there was so many
struggles, so many problems
and so we're very lucky that we
have the videophones nowadays
and we're very happy for it.
>> Hi, my name is Jacinda
[inaudible].
Yes and I used to work on the help
desk support group, tech help desk
and I remember assisting some
of the staffs with the Sorinsen.
Sorensen, am I saying
that correctly,
and I would like to know how much
it has progressed these days.
Am I saying that right, Sorensen.
>> Yeah, it is there, it
has improved things greatly,
we're using, we're adding
a lot of technology.
And a lot of things
that we use here's
that people are very satisfied
with it as they add features;
people are becoming very comfortable
with it, so it's tremendous.
I'm kind of old-fashioned, I
don't use lot of the new things
or features but they are out there.
>> Alex Richey: And here
at the Library every deaf permanent
employee has a video phone,
it's really great to have
the videophones at our desk.
The communication is
much more facile,
it's faster and it's easier to use.
>> Even when I go outside of the
Library, I'm on my cell phone,
I have the same technology
built-in, and with FaceTime.
>> Alex Richey: So I think many of
you are familiar with FaceTime and
but that's only within the Apple
products within iPhone but it's face
to face time and so if you have
FaceTime you can actually use that.
Now, Androids I'm not sure
if that technology has those.
>> Yeah, I have Sorensen the
app actually in my phone,
so that works fine for me.
>> Fred Pickering: And when you
talk about FaceTime, on the iPhone
but really other devices use, other
smartphones have a similar system.
It's an equivalent thing anyway
to the iPhone's FaceTime system.
IMO, I don't know if
you've seen that,
you can download that for free.
It's not an app like that,
my daughter has that,
it doesn't play well with FaceTime
but you can download those.
>> Alex Richey: and I'm
wondering about Skype?
Do you use Skype?
>> Skype, I don't use
Skype much, no.
>> Alex Richey: Are
there, is a new technology?
This is a question
from the audience.
Could you talk about
GLIDE, G L I D E?
>> Yeah, you record
yourself in a short message
and you send it that off.
>> Alex Richey: It's
much like texting
for people for hearing people.
>> Fred Pickering: And
for the video phones,
we use the video phones
everyday but issues come
up about what about emergencies.
We can, you dial 911 as well on
the video phone, it's very easy
to do from a video phones.
It's the same process,
the person instead
of automatically we get it
pushed to the top of the queue
for anybody to call obviously.
Interpreters there are trained
to handle that and they did
that to a special 911
process that they go through.
The answer right away, we explain
situation, heart attack, whatever,
fire and they call,
and they call them out,
but unfortunately but
the system in place.
Here at the Library the interpreter
automatically hold the DC police
rather than the Capital police.
So we're working on that now,
try and figure out how to get
that dealt with, get that rerouted.
Someone coming out of the
library should be going
to the Capital police; they should
be the ones coming to our offices
to [inaudible] first
responders for us.
So that is dragging
things out a bit,
if it gets out to the wrong folks,
if it gets out to the DC police
rather than the Capital police.
But we wouldn't really want to
have go in outside the government
to then be brought back into to
have the DC police trying to get
into the government
building such so.
We're trying to work around for
that but it's taking a lot of time
and it is sort of dragging
the process out.
>> Alex Richey: And so now, we
talked about all this technology,
but I do you want to ask a couple
questions about clubs for the deaf?
Many of them are closing and
let me repeat that, I guess.
The number of deaf clubs,
some people may not be
familiar with deaf clubs.
These were places that in your
local area you could get together
with deaf people and get together
to talk with each other directly
in American sign language
but then with the advent
of technology especially with
the VPs we don't get together
and socialize at the
deaf clubs anymore
and so clubs are waning
across America.
>> Fred Pickering: The deaf
clubs were very popular,
every weekend everybody
went to the club.
If you're in different state,
a different town you found a
deaf club and you went there.
Everybody knew where they were,
it was where the community
was centered.
And more and more of them have
been closing; I'm not sure if it's
that the people just
aren't interested any longer
or if the technology is sort
of replacing that connection.
People used to go to the club to
catch up on what was going on,
what's happening in your
life, what are we up to,
and what are we not up to?
Now we've got email, we've got
videophones, we've got texting,
we've got all these things.
All those connections may
be replacing some of that.
The organization still there for
a lot of deaf seniors, the NAD,
the National Association of the Deaf
is also still there but it is sad
to see a lot of that sort of
culture base disappearing.
>> I know before like in World War
II there were, everybody went off
to the war, everybody except for
the deafened, the deaf Americans.
We stayed here and we were
actually housed in machinery
in fact factory type of
buildings and assembly lines.
The noise didn't bother
us and so that was a time
that we were all able to
get together and that was
where a sense of community began.
>> Alex Richey: And so
and I think that that's
where you're saying the deaf
clubs got to start, yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Alex Richey: So let's look
ahead and talk about the future
and what you would like
to see in the future.
And we'll entertain questions
from the audience as well.
>> Specifically with education and
Gallaudet's still going strong.
We understand that cochlear
implants have had an effect
and now children are growing up
in complete mainstream schools
and with cochlear implants.
So kids aren't growing up
with that, with signing.
>> Alex Richey: Is that
a concern that you have
about the children coming up
and them not learning deaf
cultures, is that your concern?
>> Yes, yes.
>> This may be a little unrelated
to telecommunication but I would say
that captioning on TV
has been really great.
That technology actually
helped us improve our English
and our comfortability
with written English.
And we're finding out that
second-language learners of English,
immigrant communities coming in to
learn the English have benefited
from captioning on televisions.
>> Fred Pickering: In the
current technology as far
as an affect the future,
I don't know what it's
going to look like exactly.
I know we have the pagers,
we have the videophones,
we have captioning
etcetera, etcetera.
That's left, I'm not
sure to meet our needs,
they're fairly well met I think.
I'm sure something new will pop up
then will impress the heck out of us
but I've looked on some websites and
videotapes things that are going on,
things that are happening.
I know that a lot of
that is not captioned,
so I'd like to see some sort of
technology to help with that,
some of the like online video.
I know that FTC is wanting people to
require access for the online videos
and such, they need to have
captions by like 2017 I think it is.
They are working on that to
perhaps bring the deaf people on up
to on par with the hearing
folks watch those videos.
>> Alex Richey: I've just
remembered that we used to talk
about the vlogs, video logs,
kind of like what hearing
people use as blogging.
There's a lot of the deaf people
using logging or vlogging nowadays.
>> Yeah, anytime I want to
make announcement to talk
about current events, a lot
of the vlogs are being made.
>> Alex Richey: The sign for
the vlog is this, video log.
>> You can use that
for announcements,
you just record yourself
and your signing.
>> Alex Richey: Or you get a lot
of complaints and people talking
about the hot topics on vlogs.
>> Or jokes, I mean it can
be something more neutral.
>> It gets pretty thick so
I used to avoid vlogs a lot.
>> Alex Richey: Any other
questions about the future,
how much you think technology
will do as time goes forward?
>> I think the new technology in the
future will be some 3D technology,
you know, they will just
have persons pop up.
He has an imagination.
>> I would [inaudible], I can
imagine, that will be great
to actually have a person
that your signings to a robot
or a personal interpreter
assistant when I need one,
that will be great,
a robot interpreter.
>> Fred Pickering: The thing
that can follow me around
and interpret had an communication
like that because currently if I get
in a situation where I need an
interpret, I have to either find one
or have more limited communication
or writing back and forth
but if there were something there
to sign immediately,
that will be fantastic.
There will be here to have some
sort of constant interpreter.
>> Alex Richey: A question from
the audience, let me repeat it.
When you talk about a
personal robot assistance,
something that might be likely
in the future and I'm wondering
if they would end up
having their own conferences
of robots interpreters
getting together.
>> Fred Pickering: I've seen
research says that they work more
like sign to speech that
is something that kind
of watch your sign and some sort
of technology that can convert
that into some kind
of English or speech.
So that can be sent
to a hearing person;
that will be very nice
in the future.
When that will happen, I don't know.
Money is probably an issue,
developing that sort of thing,
that kind of AI kind of stuff.
>> Alex Richey: I've seen that and
I know the people are trying to work
on that kind of technology
either voicing from sign
or robots doing sign language.
>> Alex Richey: There's
a question about,
in hospitals using video relay
services for interpreters.
I haven't had a lot of
experience with that.
Has either of you had
experience with that?
>> No, I know I always
have an interpreter there.
>> Yeah and I have seen
that the interpreter
in the video there having a person,
having a little cart that they bring
around with them with
the camera on it.
A lot of people have seen
that and they just use
like a Wi-Fi connection to do this
here with the picture the person
in some of the other
office or something.
But it is nice to use it
in a hospital but a lot
of deaf people really when they are
waiting to talk with the doctor need
to have that interpreted.
So they're running to sign them,
they have these little cart
on wheels with a laptop
with a camera on it
and they're dragging it around.
Because sometimes if you
call for an interpreter
in an emergency will say it takes
a while for them to get there.
So it is nice to have that
option there, I have seen that.
>> Okay, any other questions
or discussions about technology
in the deaf community
before we close?
I guess, Toby I think we're ready
for you to come up and close us out
and will wait a minute, I think
there is another question.
>> How large will be
[inaudible] how large [inaudible].
>> Alex Richey: Which
model are you speaking of?
It was this wide and this deep
and about that tall so about that
and then some of them
were table top models
but mine was a full floor model,
that's the one that I remember.
And Fred's said they were very heavy
and there's another
question from the back.
Does anyone still have an old TTY,
no, we got rid of those Gerald said.
They were so noisy,
you wouldn't want
to have them, they shook the house.
I have something to add, I remember
in the apartment that I lived
in way back when, it was a second
floor and I would make calls
but then all of a sudden
I realized that someone
on the third floor was using
a ham radio that was kind
of interfering with the signal.
And so later on I found out that
is there was another deaf guy
that was using a ham radio.
I'm sorry, a hand.
It wasn't a deaf person that was
using it, it was a hearing person
that was using it on the
third floor that interfered
with the signal that I was using.
>> Fred Pickering: and we
all had to stop at eleven,
we couldn't use it after eleven.
>> Alex Richey: The neighbors
below complained about the noise
of the TTY so I had to cut it
off, no calls after eleven.
There's another question.
I guess for Fred.
And I'll repeat the question.
Now, I understand that with video
phones, you can't use a video phone
from one room to another?
>> With the FCC regulation
limits that.
If you're in the same
room with the deaf person,
you should just bring
an interpreter in.
The issue is, they
decided to play it safe
and require that through the FCC.
If a person is calling
through a video phone you have
to be somewhere else, you
can't be in the room with them.
If you're in the same room that
is not allowed, it would be nice
but if you're going to be
in the same room together you
should have interpreter there,
is their feeling.
The FCC's regulation is
going to eat into their money
that they are collecting
to pay for that service
if they're placing people
having interpreters on-site.
>> Yeah, because that
services is covered
by VRI Video Relay Interpreting,
not Video Relay Service,
remote interpreting not VRS.
>> Alex Richey: Alright, any.
You would ask the question again?
So what about personal
communication in a real-life time
on the video phones or texting,
would you prefer simultaneous
communication?
Excuse me, let me repeat
the question.
You can repeat the question, Fred.
>> If you have like a cell phone
and a mobile device and you are able
to put that app up, is
that not the same thing?
Can you use that through your phone?
>> Fred Pickering: You have to use
the Wi-Fi if you're really here
in the building, you
can't get a good signal
and the Wi-Fi does
not really allow that.
So when you're outside of
the Library, you get a signal
that you can use, fine, you
make those calls through an app,
through a relay service
whatever on your phone.
But when you're inside the Library
you don't get very good signal,
so the Wi-Fi does does not
allow that kind of bandwidth.
>> Alex Richey: So we need to
repeat the question for the person.
>> Alex Richey: Okay, alright,
we'll go back to asking
her question directly, so.
>> Fred Pickering: I think what
she is saying and correct me
if I'm wrong, when we we're
here at work coworkers,
if you need an interpreter you
can't get an interpreter working
with coworkers.
Can I use the video phone there
on my cell phone, make that easier
to do that and if you're
in the same room, you mean?
I understand what you're
talking about now.
Whether it's a videophone on your
desktop or videophone on your phone,
on your cell phone,
it's the same rules.
So the videophones, it is
not permitted to do that,
you're not going to be
able to, you can't use them
in place of an interpreter.
So that's a good question,
I don't believe so.
>> Alex Richey: So we have
about ten minutes left.
And other follow up questions?
Any additional questions?
>> Can I ask about the blogging
that he was speaking of earlier,
is there a method for transcribing
that which is being spoken
in the sign language for
those who [inaudible]?
>> Well, it's like, you know,
when it's in words and in English,
we don't have captions so now you
kind of know what's like for us.
>> I guess, you know,
there is a discussion
about whether video sign
communication should have captioning
in English and people in
the audience are saying
that there are some video logs
that they will add captioning
but they have to, this
is Fred speaking.
They have to definitely be prepared
to have the transcriber ready
and to have the technology ready
to put the English captions
on a video communication.
But that's a really good point.
Thanks for bringing that up.
Alex speaking [inaudible].
Anything else before we close here?
>> Can I ask one follow
up to that [inaudible]?
>> Sure.
>> I'm wondering, there's
the availability of like,
for example with virtual
reality where they used
to have the glove that
use to [inaudible]?
I'm wondering if that
would be something
that they should approach
for transcription.
>> Possibly, so in other words a
person doing video on their computer
for persons that understand the
English they can have it translated
into German, Japanese,
Greek, things like that.
You can do that with the written
language there on your computer
but I'm not sure how that applies
[inaudible] spoken language
but if you have gloves or something
like that you might be able
to be aware of where you are
and what you doing in space,
but the signing itself how
your hands are in space,
it should be able to capture
that but as far as translating
that into an English written
English thing I don't know
that the technology is there yet.
So what if I'm signing something,
I'm not sure that you'll be able
to translate that specifically
into an English phrase
but facial expressions,
body language,
all that sort of stuff would
be lost in the translation
which is a big part of the language.
So people reading sort of reading
my behaviour, reading my emotions
that maybe something
that comes later.
>> Alex Richey: Alex speaking,
yes facial expressions
and grammar is very
important not just the hands.
Okay, Toby would you like to say
something else as we close out?
No, thank you.
So Alex is saying thank you everyone
for on behalf of the Library
of Congress Deaf Association
for coming out to this program.
I think it's been very interesting
and I hope you enjoyed it.
And I hope you enjoyed this program,
and we'll see you at
the next program.
Thank you everyone.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov